justin tell us about the first six
months of developing
a storyline and characters for your
script sure
um first i'll say that i think every
writer's approach is probably different
so i can only speak on
my approach personally but i would say
that
the first thing that you have to do is
figure out the
story that you want to tell so it's
really about a concept that you come up
with
based on that concept you start to think
about
the overall story the act breakdowns
when things are going to happen where
they need to happen so
a crucial element for me specifically is
storyboarding and getting your boards
done so
breaking down each act breaking down
each scene
making sure that there is you know
conflict in each scene that you have
making sure that there are emotional
shifts between your characters
making sure that they're getting from
point a to point b
in the time that you need them to get
there and making sure that they have
arcs and there's growth
so i think that's a major part of it on
top of that is
is developing your characters within
that story so i think you start with
your protagonist you start with your
antagonist
you start to pepper in you know the
potential love story
or the b stories or the c stories and i
just always make sure
this is part of the reason why i spend
so much time on character development
whether that's you know two three four
months
is because i want to make sure that
every single character has a story to
tell
and starts one way and ends another way
so
i'm i'm very apparent about getting an
arc out of all my characters
so with those storyboards you can really
see who is where what they're doing
and dissect why they're doing it so it's
an incredible
incredibly important part of the process
of of telling a story because
you know i as i mentioned before i know
some people that just sit down and start
writing
and i don't know that that's the best
approach it might work for some people
but i don't think it works for a lot of
other people for most writers because
you really have to know the exact story
it has to be bulletproof before you
start sitting down and writing that
dialogue out or writing the scenes out
or writing
you know the script so
the development process of this story is
crucial
and i would just recommend if you don't
know how to do it on your own read the
books that it takes to
know how to do that if you do know how
to do it stay
vigilant and dedicated to that process
and you know i think there's some
enjoyment out of boards sometimes
because
you get to see that story start coming
to fruition in front of you
and you're not too far in and too deeply
attached yet
you're still creating this world the way
that you want to create it